[Applaudissements]
oui j'ai la courbe et je me suis fais
draguer effectivement par une star de la
télé lancé benoît dumas d'énergie
[Applaudissements]
je trouve que c'est un bon début ayant
également à dos et qui tourne sur julien
courbet abbas que c'est vrai que le
président avait hérité dans un instant
je vais vous le dire maintenant à aller
à l'eau ce qui tourne sur vous dites
nous si c'est vrai il paraît que vous
êtes fait draguer par martine aubry quoi
la vérité mais non c'est pas vrai c'est
une veine que je les ouvriers mais ses
producteurs qui médite était déjà fait
draguer par une somme aux jouets en bois
oui martine aubry
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à voir mais moi j'ai capoté et vous
sucer appris combien de temps non
[Applaudissements]
cobourne sirigu 2